what was once considered pure fantasy in
movies like Avatar it's now looking a
little more plausible
earlier this week NASA announced the
discovery of a possible earth-like
planet located just 31 light-years away
a hop skip and a jump in cosmic terms
that may be able to support life I think
it's an amazing discovery we have this
small mission called Tess that's
scanning the whole sky where the
brightest and closest objects to find
planets like ours and this is the first
one the planet named GJ 3 5 7 D is six
times larger than Earth it orbits a
dwarf star with two other previously
unknown planets this potential super
earth is located within the outer edge
of its star's habitable zone where it
receives about the same amount of
stellar energy as Mars does from the Sun
if this planet has a dense atmosphere it
could trap enough heat to allow for
liquid water on its surface you have a
huge planet basically a chubby cousin if
you will then you'd expect there to be a
lot of atmosphere in that atmosphere
again could capture that heat and make
it warm enough where they dip in liquid
water this amazing discovery was made
possible by NASA's training exoplanet
survey satellite or tests for short
but that spacecraft just pointed the way
to next generation telescopes coming
online in the next six years promised a
much more detailed view including
whether the planet has mountains or
oceans just like here on earth
and Tess actually will continue to go
through 2022 so who knows what else a
super-earth only takes 31 years to get
there